WE'LL BE BACK MONDAY.
HAVE A GREAT WEEK.
>> Bret: GOOD EVENING, WELCOME
TO WASHINGTON.
I AM BRET BAIER.
THE HISTORIC PROCESS OF
IMPEACHMENT COLLIDES WITH
SOCIAL MEDIA TO PRODUCE A BIG
MOMENT
REPUBLICANS QUESTIONED IF SHE
HAD ANY FIRST-HAND INFORMATION
ABOUT THE MAIN ALLEGATION OF
QUID PRO QUO, NOW CALLED BRIBERY
BY THE DEMOCRATS.
SHE ANSWERED THAT SHE DID NOT.
BUT THE PRESIDENT'S TWEET HANDED
THE DEMOCRATS A GIFT DURING THAT
HEARING TODAY.
WE HAVE FOX TEAM COVERAGE.
JOHN ROBERTS AT THE WHITE HOUSE
WITH THE PRESIDENT TAKING
MATTERS IN HIS OWN HANDS AND
FINGERS, 280 AT A TIME.
WE START OFF A CHIEF
CORRESPONDENT MIKE EMANUEL ON A
FULL AND INTERESTING DAY.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS NOT ON
CAPITOL HILL FOR TODAY'S HEARING
BUT HIS USE OF HEARING IN AN
ATTACK BUT THE PRESIDENT IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE ACTION.
A PRESIDENTIAL TWEET THE RING
AMBASSADOR MARIE YOVANOVITCH IS
TESTIMONY ROCKS TODAY'S HEARING.
>> I WILL READ ONE OF HIS
TWEETS.
EVERYWHERE MARIE YOVANOVITCH
WENT TURNED BAD.
SHE STARTED IN SOMALIA, HOW DID
THAT GO?
>> EVERYWHERE MARIE YOVANOVITCH
WENT BAD, STARTED OFF IN
SOMALIA, WHERE DID THAT GO,
FAST-FORWARD TO UKRAINE WHERE
THE NEW UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT
SPOKEN FAVORABLY ABOUT HER IN MY
SECOND PHONE CALL WITH HIM.
IT'S THE U.S. PRESIDENT'S
ABSOLUTE RIGHT TO APPOINT
AMBASSADORS.
AND THEN YOVANOVICH REACTED TO
THE ATTACK IN REAL TIME.
>> I CAN'T SPEAK TO WHAT THE
PRESIDENT IS TRYING TO DO BUT I
THINK THE EFFECT IS TO BE
INTIMIDATING.
>> ADAM SCHIFF QUICKLY LABELED
IT "WITNESS INTIMIDATION" AND
ANOTHER WORD HAS EMERGED IN THE
DEMOCRATIC LEXICON.
>> WHAT THE PRESIDENT HAS
ADMITTED TO AND SAYS IT'S
PERFECT, I SAID IT'S PERFECT.
IT'S BRIBERY.
>> THE DCCC HAS BEEN CONDUCTING
FOCUS GROUPS IN KEY HOUSE
BATTLEGROUNDS WHICH FOUND THE
TERM BRIBERY THE MOST DAMNING
DESCRIPTION OF THE CONFLICT OVER
QUID PRO QUO OR EXTORTION.
>> WE ARE NOT HERE TO TALK ABOUT
TWEETS.
>> REPUBLICANS WAS A PRIVATELY
ACKNOWLEDGE THE TRUMP TWEET WAS
DAMNING TO THEIR SIDE PAID FOR
THE MOST PART, G.O.P. LAWMAKERS
DID NOT ATTACK YOVANOVICH'S QUIT
ABILITY, DIRECTING MOST OF THEIR
FIRE TO SCHIFF'S HANDLING OF THE
PROCESS.
>> ARE AT INDULGENCE WITH YOU
WITHOUT A LONG TIME AGO, MR. CHA
WITHOUT A LONG TIME AGO, MR. CHR
WITHOUT A LONG TIME AGO, MR. CH.
>> CLAIMS DUE TO A CAMPAIGN OF
DISINFORMATION OF CORRUPT
UKRAINIAN INTEREST.
>> WE HAVE A NEW ADMINISTRATION
IN UKRAINE THAT DID NOT HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN THIS AMBASSADOR.
>> EMMA CRADDICK MIKE QUIGLEY
MOCK TO THE PUBLIC
EVERYTHING WORKED OUT WELL.
>> IT'S NOT THE END OF A
HALLMARK MOVIE.
IT'S THE END OF THE REALLY BAD
REALITY TV SHOW BROUGHT TO YOU
BY SOMEONE WHO KNOWS A LOT ABOUT
THEM.
>> WHAT IT WAS OVER, WITNESS
DREW APPLAUSE AND LAWMAKERS WENT
BEHIND CLOSED DOOR TO QUESTION
DAVID HOLMES BASED ON NEW
EVIDENCE.
HOLMES OVERHEARD A CELL PHONE
CONVERSATION BETWEEN AMBASSADOR
TO THE E.U. GORDON SONDLAND AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHEN AMBASSADOR
BILL TAYLOR SAYS THE PRESIDENT
WAS FOCUSED ON THE
INVESTIGATIONS.
THAT SETS THE STAGE FOR NEXT